I had just finished my freshman year of
college I was out in the ocean and I
drove out into a way of something I've
done many times before I drove into a
sandbar that had drifted in which
fractured my spine and damaged my spinal
cord and that left me as a c5
quadriplegic
I kept asking the doctors what can I
look forward to in the future
one of my doctors said hey we want to
try this muscle stimulation device it
really sounds like it's something out of
a science fiction novel reconnecting my
mind to my body
spinal trauma is one of the toughest
problems in medicine there's currently
no biological way of healing severe
damage to the spinal cord
recently scientists have started
developing who work around creating an
artificial link between the brain and
the body
[Music]
my name is Gaurav Sharma I'm a lead
investigator on the neural life program
at Bedell so new life is an electronic
neural bypass technology that can link
the brain directly to the limit controls
we are developing this technology for
people with paralysis due to spinal cord
injury so that they can regain control
of their own hand
Ian Burkhart
is at first pigeon in the study being
injured at the c5 level means the
relation I have pretty good strength
through my biceps but I don't really
have any movement below my elbows at all
if I on other people to help me every
single day
they help me get dressed get transferred
into my wheelchair brush my hair and
then at the end of the day also need
help doing everything in Reverse to get
ready for bed independence is my number
one goal and regaining any use of my
hands will really improve my
independence so something that was all
for
[Music]
yes so this technology has three main
component the first component is a tiny
chip that is surgically implanted in
Ian's brain and that record in brain
activity as he's thinking about moving
his hand through a little more slack
that's fine good okay cool yeah the
second component is a computer algorithm
that decodes in brain activity and
interprets the movement that he's
thinking about
and the last component is a variable
sleeve which had up 260 electrode which
activates the individual muscles to
evoke the attempted movement
he said hit open first hand open versa
when I first started with the city just
trying to open and close my hand was
extremely challenging I never had to
think about moving my hand it was just
something that naturally happened so it
was something that took a lot of mental
strength okay you ready yeah
[Music]
but today with practice I'm able to pick
up object and manipulate that around in
space
I'm able to move individual fingers I
can do some complex grasps
you're looking good today yeah you know
we've done everything from picking up a
bottle and pouring it to playing guitar
hero just being able to control more of
your body that I thought I had lost
forever is something that's really
exciting and really promising
[Music]
all right so I think we're going to play
as Ian gets better at using his hand the
researchers give him new challenges this
is his first time trying this homemade
battleship game and the results are a
mixed bag they'll look better I think
yeah I barely had a hold of it and I
looked in its what happens when you try
a new thing though I think you were
getting bored with everything working
easily nice to mix things up a little
bit it's probably going to be a while
before a system like narrow life
restores anything like full
functionality but it's a first step
towards a future where a broken
connection between mind and body doesn't
have to be permanent for now Patel plans
to keep refining the system with Ian and
other patients in the hope of turning
Nero life into a commercial product
within a few years the ultimate goal of
this project is someone can actually
take it home with them and use it for
their activities of daily living
we are working very hard on the hardware
size to make it portable and wearable so
that Ian can in the morning wake up put
the sleeve on and it should be good to
go if I can help move science so that in
the future someone with a injury like
mine
they'll be back going on with their
lives in a short time
that's something that you know I'll work
as hard as I can for
[Music]
you